according to Wall Street Journal tipping
Has Come For self-serve checkout so you
and the Machine and the machine says
money please this is wild so prompts to
leave twenty percent of self-checkout
machines at airport stadiums cookie
shops cafes across the country are
rankling consumers already inundated by
the proliferation of tip screens how
many ten dollar words could this author
fit in here it is the Wall Street
Journal and here's the crazy part
business owners say the odd the
automated cues can significantly
increase gratuities and boost staff pay
you know what else could boost staff pay
paying them more not cheap uh bosses and
leaders and here's a quote from a senior
at American University in DC they're
cutting labor costs by doing
self-checkout so what's the point of
asking for a tip and where is it going
and tipping researchers didn't know that
was a job uh the labor Advocates say
so-called tip creep is a way for
employers to put the onus for the
employee to pay on to Consumers rather
than raising wages themselves companies
say tips are an optional thanks for a
job well done